what do you think the average body count
is for someone your age and just you
know we're not saying this is your body
count anyway just based on stories
you've heard people you know around you
say your age first and what you would
guess the average body count is I'm 25
I'd guess the average body count for
around for a woman sorry for a woman at
the age 25
and the society you were in I'm gonna
say like an average like
60 and 17. but that's just for like what
I know and what I've been about that's
all I can say you would say 16 17.
that's all I can yeah that's what I can
calm down um I'm 21 and I'd say average
I think it's important to say in the
western culture in the west yeah yeah um
I think it would probably be around 12
to 20 12 to 20 yeah for 21. yeah okay
especially someone not being at Uni or
whatnot wow yeah I like genuinely yes
okay
I am 33 and I think that average body
count is
25 30.
okay complete guess
so I'm 23 and I'd say the same as Aisha
probably like 15 to 20. 15 to 20 what
would you say I'm 55 I was gonna say 10.
I was doubling numbers I was thinking
well if it's five for me it must be 10
for everybody else I think about 10 or
55. and so you would say um women your
age that are married or single would you
say the same yeah
10. yeah okay what do you guys think I'm
a grandma
how old are you I'm 30. and you would
say 10 say about 10. I'm 26 and I'd say
15 to 20 15 to 20. I'm curious from the
guys what do you guys think it is
say your age first we'll go through yeah
I'm uh 37 and I I would say it's
probably around 20.
for 25 year old women
all 26 ish oh
I don't know man it depends the girl I'm
thinking about right now you're free
you're free
now you gotta think about it you say
about 50.
how how many bodies does it take for a
girl to become a hoe
oh I think I I genuinely think if if
you're
I'm gonna say ten I do think 10 in a
specific age range okay so a ton by how
what age 10 by 24 100 if you're starting
at the bear rage so what about what
about 30 at 10 does she
I don't know because I think like women
especially like being 30 yeah I think
the amount of like situationships
relationships dates that go on over a
few months I'm just curious where it's
where it switches so at 30 like how many
bodies is she at home oh damn 24 10 oh
okay 30 what is it
20 to 30 20. okay go ahead
um
how many bodies does it take for a girl
to become a hoe
um
uh is I think I think it's very
complicated because there's different
scenarios in which the woman could have
had sexual intercourse okay what are the
scenarios for example if you yeah sorry
if you had like a lot of like one-night
stands and whatnot obviously I think
that is quite hot wish but if a woman
genuinely got tricked by like quite a
few guys into thinking that she was
gonna end up in a relationship by this
guy so then she sort of have you been
naive and had sex with him how many how
many how many how many times does a girl
have to have sex with someone for it to
not be naivety anymore so you know do
you mean like one person
so you have sex with one guy let's say
but he tricks you okay Bamboozled you
thought you're gonna get into a
relationship he says baby it's you you
have sex it's in fact not you then you
do it again the guy says baby it's you
you have sex with him he says in fact it
is not you then there's a third guy he
says baby baby baby
it was still not you so then the fourth
guy comes around okay and you know I've
never heard anyone when I asked this
question I've never heard anyone say
four so so far four like men are okay
with right so the fourth guy comes
around he says Baby It's You
but then in fact was not you again how
many times like were you naive and how
many times were you just making a choice
I don't know again I think depending on
age
um again it varies but I think anything
more than like double digits could be
considered a whole okay and by what age
roughly
um
let's say about my age I think even
double digits after my age I think you
said you're 21. yeah okay 21 10 okay
fair
agree double digits by 20s
it's questionable
go ahead I agree but also
for myself as well I think it kind of is
based on how you present yourself
because if you was like low-key and
nobody knew anything about you how would
anyone be able to call you a hire
whereas if you're out displaying your
business and you could have maybe had
sex with one person then people might
call you at home from the way you're
presenting it so if it was an only
person well then then you would just be
a secret hell yeah
but but I but I'm act for you what do
you think I agree with what they said
but I just think roughly 10 by 20s yeah
okay you're hitting double digits then
I'm gonna get the answer from the girls
and then we're gonna go to the guys so
Auntie Jenny
I think five by 25 otherwise you're
gonna be a leftover I think five by
twenty five after any number that stops
a man from one in your Marion is too
high
so I think that it shouldn't be women
that decided a high number it should be
men and if a man says five's too high
then five's too high if a man says twos
do I it's like right now men are saying
they want virgins so all these are wrong
um go ahead I'm just asking each person
I don't teach to their own that's how
I'm asking everyone yeah so I'm not sure
I think as a consent in adult as long as
you're both single I I find the whole
sleeping with people and making you a
hoe I don't really get it but what else
would make you a hoe I think sleeping
with maybe people that are in
relationships or being unsafe like if
you're protecting yourself so like yeah
so if this week I slept with 20 dudes
but but I use condoms I was being safe
right so am I not at home yeah no I get
what you mean yeah depending on the
space I guess as well like how do I put
pants so I'm asking like what what would
quantify how and what would not so it's
probably in the space of a short period
of time a large number Okay so
uh let's say two guys in six months oh
we're not a hoe
no matter how four guys in six months
yeah probably that's a bit wild for
foreign okay what about uh lifetime ten
oh we're not a hoe I don't think that's
100 20 lifetime
lifetime
I'd say 25 let's just say oh then yeah I
mean it's it's questionable so that's
maybe I'm just asking your personal
opinion now yeah I think it's
questionable but so 20 is not is almost
a hoe almost yeah almost but not quite
there yet Thirty Thirty
yeah probably 30. okay so 30 is a hoe
okay go ahead I think 530 High because
how many times can you get it wrong
but
that's my own opinion okay now
men
you go first
let's let's say uh 20 25 year old girl
what do you think give me 25 and give me
30.
um
I don't know what we 25 I think when you
start hitting friend groups and [__]
like okay you know you know you don't
caught two from this friend group uh two
from this friend group then you hung
around at that point Cause you gotta
think about I see I'm thinking realistic
okay
when girls gone girls trips they be that
that don't buy discount when that first
week of college when girls go to college
you know I know girl be wild or not that
[__] count so this 20 number that that
they give to I I don't know maybe it's
America I don't know or down south but
is that what that says I'm from America
I'm from down south but I never went on
a girls trip and wild out
no Lord hammers yeah man tinked out we
get into college girl yeah
uh
he hits one of you kind of wildly you're
kind of Wilding at 25 years old
yeah
a 25 20. yeah and that's 24 years and 24
years and what do you think the average
body count is what did you say earlier
oh you said like 40 or 50 right
for girl yeah I like 30 something like
that or 30 okay 35 something okay what
do you but it might not be crazy I don't
know
I don't know how okay it's just your
opinion it's not you know he's not fussy
I think I like 20
at like 25
after five to six it's like
how many times you gonna mess this up
how many times five or six relationship
but they haven't sent outside of just
people who they in a relationship with
everyone's saying everyone
it's crazy well the thing is like if you
okay well the thing is like at five to
six most don't because like they don't
consider it as mess-ups
right like they don't they don't
consider us lessons yeah like lessons
like oh I learned from that experience
favorite things but that lesson [__]
right don't like
to a degree learn from their mistakes
but Wise Women mature women High
achieving women
are gonna learn from others five or six
by the time you 25 and she she only got
five with his body man you man oh you
better keep that that's a good one
I think went like to every team nowadays
five or six at the age of 25. do you
know what's that to me is that when
everybody's talking about their numbers
you're not talking about six months that
that's a relationship yeah but see what
I mean it's like what I have people say
one every six months or two in six
months and I'm thinking [__] don't
people have sex like for years you know
that you're having sex for like two
years minimum but now it's like I have
sex on a date I have sex for a week yeah
I'm in a situationship everybody just
wants to be out there having sex
that's what media is nowadays that's
what it is
you can have sex on your own you don't
need men yeah what is that I have a
really good question which is worse a
girl with five bodies in one year all in
all one night stands or five bodies in
one year all attempts at a relationships
that were two to three months each oh
that one the second one 100 you're
looking into all the red flags and just
accepting them straight away but you're
not just doing it willy-nilly like I'm
out on a nightclub I'm just gonna go off
with him for the night but you're
actually putting like because women we
we put our trust into men first of all
we're not just going to be like oh no
he's doing nothing whatever you're
putting your trust into these men over
these six months
one night stands because to me that's
borderline you might as well be a sex
worker get paid for your work at least
you're out here giving volunteer away
just what you doing just
yeah actually I thought this question
was gonna be different I read it wrong I
think this is actually a pretty easy
answer
um okay I'm gonna read the super chats
really quick uh make sure you guys like
the video guys
um a like is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams so uh make sure you like the
video also guys all Super Chat blessing
what are we saving for right now
blessing is always bleeding me dry how
do we how do we have one of the best
sets on YouTube I do have the best
producer in the game I will say blessing
is phenomenal he is so smart but he does
bleed me dry so please send donations or
what do you want blessing I'm trying to
go to the USA we need the Visa money
yeah guys we are we are our goal is to
move you know we Face some
discrimination in this apartment complex
I'm not going to get too much into it
um but you know they've been causing us
some issues so we have to look at other
options you know we may be moving to the
US in the fall so all donations help so
we can do that because it is going to be
very expensive when we do move
um we may leave an office here I don't
know depends on how we're doing so you
know send donations anyways
John Crowder thank you for the Super
Chat black is Panther
um I read your question earlier Robert
Harold if your body count is higher than
your age you should chill
um feelings monogamy says more than one
light water FTR
um ft I think MTR men think you're a 304
after two
um Lord's honesty comedy someone must be
really someone must have had someone
must have had a really fishy scent Mel
is pissed
as somebody's lost 67 pounds I'm sorry
I'm tired of women saying they're plus
size and won't admit that they have
healthy habits unhealthy habits Pierre
right we love you Mel um you speak facts
but you got to let others get the get a
word in you're overtaking the
conversation Emily I was raised to be a
housewife that took care of homes if I
didn't have a job and a career as if I
didn't have a job and to have a career
as if I didn't have kids or a family
anyone else zero Fallout so much uh
yeast in these streets call them Sarah
Lee Dash a munch on who is more
who is more precious
uh who is more precious or more valuable
the painting which is priceless or the
painting that is worth one million life
University is watching action movies and
shaming violence hypocritical obviously
not as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible